What is the best way to deal with constipation?
Well, again, like everything you want to find out why.
So one of the reasons why you have constipation is that you're not properly properly digesting, especially proteins.
So if you have mild constipation by first thing is to start taking some HCL and digestive enzyme.
So taking like our clear digest product would be a good one or any HCL and digestive enzyme product would be a good one, especially when you're, you know, you take that with your meals.
So you're always asking the question, why, you know, all I just prone to constipation, you know, get more difficult moments and things.
Then also think about adding magnesium, especially for bad taking some magnesium, magnesium malate or magnesium glycinate or good magnesium sources to help with constipation.
But magnesium does is basically if you kind of a little bit over goes on magnesium before you go to bed, then magnesium will be dumped into the bowel and magnesium be an ion will draw water.
So you can't be dehydrated or it won't work, but if you're drinking plenty of water and you take a little bit too much magnesium, you know, harm in taking too much magnesium because you just dump it into the bowel any excess.
So you can't be injured by taking too much magnesium, magnesium is a necessary co factor in about 500 different metabolic processes in your body.
So most people are deficient in magnesium, you know, if their diet isn't, you know, you know, high and vegetables and such.
So magnesium is a good thing for everybody to be taking if you take too much magnesium, you will again, like I said, dump it into the bowel and that will draw water and it will loosen your stools.
Now, if you take even, you know, way too much magnesium, you'll dump more into the bowel and then a little bit of your stools, even more.
So you just got to be careful with that because you can kind of have diarrhea the next day and well, that's not pleasant.
So you have to kind of find the dose that's right for you.
If a person calls me and says, I've done magnesium and magnesium has always worked for me, but I've just been so concentrated on what's wrong with me.
Then the thing to do is to use Cape Allo. So Cape Allo is just a, it's a different type of allos. Allo, Barbara essence, it's not like an allo liquid, allo that you would drink to help heal your gut.
Cape Allo is the type of allo that really causes you to have a good ball movement if you're really constipated.
Another product is cascara sagrada that is an herb that's liquid herb. I don't have a picture of that here, but that can be helpful personally. I would first recommend the Cape Allo.
It just works, it just works every time.
Taking one or two before bed will really help you clean out.
Again, we talk about this, we talk about detoxification. The worst thing you've health wise for a person is they're not really getting their body cleaned out on a regular basis.
So if you're not really feeling like you're empty empty your balls on a daily basis, that could be a major major problem.